and like capturing the essence i would  like to call it to capturing the essence  of aretha  is allowing whatever influence she had  on me to come through me versus  mimicking her or trying to recreate  everything she did because you can't do  that it's only one aretha franklin no  one understands it more than me  but to pay homage to it to pay homage to  her legacy  and to use her nuances or the way she  would approach a song like  our voice is similar in certain ways but  they're built differently our  instruments so it was like okay how do  we blend the sounds  but i think longest kept the the just of  her faith  and then sang from the soul which i  think we both do  and keep it honest i think that was the  bridge that was the thing that ty  ties it all together and so i just tried  to stay as true to that as possible  and just let her influence on me come  through me  you